In the 1953 science fiction film The Beast
from 20,000 Fathoms, a giant monster attacks
New York City — as giant monsters are known
to do.
While the film’s plot isn’t particularly
noteworthy, one element that stands out comes
about halfway through the film, when a group
of scientists try to figure out the evolutionary
history of the mysterious creature.
Our interest in the theoretical biology of
unknown lifeforms hasn’t gone anywhere.
For the past century, stories of cryptids
— like Bigfoot or the Loch Ness monster
— have continued to fascinate.
And while these creatures likely don’t exist,
that doesn’t mean it isn’t fun to speculate
on their biology.
Enter Cryptozoologicon, a book that imagines
evolutionary backstories for legendary creatures.
Created by renowned paleontologist Darren
Naish, alongside channel mainstays C.M.
Koseman and John Conway — the volume is
so detailed that I had to know more: The Archivist:
“So, where did the idea of writing a book
on the speculative biology of cryptids come
from?”
Darren Naish: “The idea did originate with
me.
I said, ‘well, there’s all these creatures
in cryptozoology that are posited as potentially
real animals, but are essentially exercises
in speculative zoology.’
The cryptozoological literature has got this
extraordinary amount of speculation about:
if these creatures are real, what are they
like, what’s their evolutionary history?”
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
investigate the imagined biology of the world’s
most famous cryptids.
You can purchase the book and follow and support
the creators using the links in the description
below.
Now, let’s explore the creatures of Cryptozoologicon…
We’ll start with the celebrities of the
cryptid world — the hairy humanoids best
known from their alleged footprints.
Darren Naish: “Obviously the most familiar
cryptids are Bigfoot, Yeti.
Every culture in the world that we know about
has legends of wild people of some kind.
I think there’s a good case to be made that
that’s a human-wide expectation I think
that’s already embedded within our cultural
landscape.”
Bigfoot and the Yeti may be a socio-cultural
phenomenon rather an undiscovered primate
species, but if we were to envision their
evolutionary history, an interesting challenge
emerges.
Just how do these speculative hominids relate
to us — and to each other?
The Cryptozoologicon team’s solution is
to imagine Bigfoot and the Yeti as large,
herbivorous apes, more closely related to
orangutans than humans.
The project imagines the Yeti and Bigfoot
to be close cousins, related sub-species possessing
different adaptations for their respective
environments.
In fact, the Cryptozoologicon team created
an entire phylogenetic tree to show how these
lineages connect not just to each other, but
to other, lesser-known ape-cryptids from around
the world.
The Orang Pendek, for example, are smaller,
red-coated humanoids from Sumatran folklore,
which the team pictures as another member
of this forgotten branch of the primate family
tree.
But this is just scratching the surface of
the team’s creativity…
Another famous yet far more unusual cryptid
comes from the folklore of the Americas.
The Chupacabra is a fabled creature said to
drain the blood from livestock like goats.
What exactly the Chupacabra is supposed to
look like varies a lot between alleged eyewitness
descriptions — from a dog-like creature,
to more of a bloodthirsty kangaroo.
If the Chupacabra were a real animal, the
team imagines it would be a semi-bipedal,
nocturnal predator.
Yet unexpectedly, the team pictures the Chupacabra
as a giant relative of the opossum.
The opossum lineage might not seem like the
one most likely to produce a bloodthirsty
terror of the night, but in fact the strong
jaws and formidable upper canines of opossums
would require little evolutionary modification
to produce a large-bodied predator.
If such a creature did roam the Americas,
one would have to be extra careful after the
sun went down...
When we think about reptilian beasts lurking
below the water, many of us might think of
the Loch Ness Monster.
But off the coast of New Zealand in 1977,
a Japanese fishing trawler reportedly found
something else.
The Zuiyo Maru Carcass was a corpse the fishing
crew accidently hauled in from the deep sea,
which many speculated was some kind of sea
monster.
Thorough analysis of amino acids in the corpse's
muscle tissue later indicated it was in fact
the carcass of a basking shark, which had
decomposed in a peculiar manner.
But what if that wasn’t the case?
The Archivist: “So, what was the team’s
thought process behind reimagining the Zuiyo
Maru Creature?”
Darren Naish: “We are thinking, if we run
with this Zuiyo Maru Creature as if it’s
an actual cryptid and a new kind of animal,
then what would it look like?
And the carcass, of course, is a decomposing
carcass, it’s not pretty, it’s got like
strands of decomposing flesh hanging off it.
So we thought: wouldn’t it be fun if that
was the creature’s real appearance?
It’s some kind of like — hideous, zombie,
deep water creature with tassels and strands
hanging off its body.
The sort of thing that we do know of in the
real world thanks to peculiar deep-sea fishes.
You know, deep sea angler fishes and what
not.”
The team goes on to speculate that perhaps
the lumps of the Zuiyo Maru Creature could
help it mimic the lumpy, muddy terrain of
the sea floor — or even mimic a rotted corpse
to appear less appetizing to predators.
In either case, it’s fun to speculate on
— even if the real explanation behind the
carcass is less spectacular...
According to Aboriginal mythology, the wilderness
of south-eastern Australia is home to a fearsome
creature known as the Bunyip.
An amorphous water monster, the Bunyip is
often described as a flippered, amphibious
animal that attacks from the water.
While some depictions of the Bunyip are quite
fantastical, others are more grounded, to
the point that some have theorized that the
Bunyip might be a cultural memory of a large,
extinct Australian marsupial, of which there
are several.
Other theories suggest that the Bunyip actually
comes from sightings of animals like the Platypus
— which frankly does look quite a bit like
a mythical creature.
But if the Bunyip were an undiscovered animal,
the team’s concept for the creature is a
semi-aquatic marsupial.
The idea of an aquatic marsupial presents
an interesting challenge, as marsupials give
birth to under-developed babies that they
raise in a pouch.
As a solution, the team proposes that like
the unusual South American water possum, the
Bunyip’s pouch has a water-tight seal.
Such an adaptation could allow the Bunyip
to thrive in aquatic environments — something
that real Australian marsupials have struggled
to do…
The tale of the Beast of Gévaudan is one
of the most genuinely interesting and intriguing
of cryptozoological mysteries.
Between 1764 and 1767 in south-eastern France,
over 70 people seemingly perished from encounters
with an enormous, wolf-like beast.
The beast quickly became legendary, and multiple
large wolves believed to be responsible for
the Beast’s attacks were slain during that
time.
Allegedly, a rogue Hyena was eventually caught
and killed as well.
As unlikely as that might sound, the animal’s
pelt was documented going on display in Paris
years later — confirming that an escaped
hyena really did briefly roam the French countryside.
In view of all this, it seems the attacks
came from numerous culprits, the stories of
which were inadvertently combined to form
the legend.
But now, let’s imagine that the Beast of
Gévaudan was a single, undiscovered monster.
Taking inspiration from reports that the beast
had curved claws and a long, slender tail,
the team interprets the creature not as a
wolf or Hyena, but a type of giant mustelid.
Mustelids are a family of carnivorous mammals
that includes otters, ferrets, and wolverines.
This version of the Beast of Gévaudan would
be an entirely new subset of the mustelid
family, and would make the European countryside
far more dangerous...
Thanks in part to a somewhat notorious faux-documentary
that aired on the Discovery Channel in 2013,
the idea that a certain bus-sized prehistoric
shark could be living undetected has become
a popular one.
The Archivist: “Given your expertise as
a paleontologist, just how outlandish is it
that the Megaladon survived into the modern
era?”
Darren Naish: “There’s no chance that
it’s still alive.
It’s not really appreciated how poor the
case is.
Lots of data on the position of megalodon
teeth in the fossil record has shown that
this shark did not survive into the Holocene
— the modern era — and it probably didn’t
even survive into the Pleistocene.
Most of them have turned out to be older than
about two million years old.
Way, way, way before the modern era.”
Yet in a speculative parallel universe where
the Megalodon did still swim the seas, what
would it look like?
In order for a whale-eating shark to remain
elusive, it would likely have to have evolved
into a deepwater fish that lurks in undersea
canyons.
The team suggests that this new, abyssal Megalodon
would be a ghostly white, and would be a separate
species from its Pliocene ancestors.
Such terrors of the deep would certainly make
swimming more nerve-wracking…
On the Indonesian island of Java, a demon
is said to fly through the mountains on leathery
wings.
Infrequent reports from the 1920s describe
the Ahool, a bat-like terror with a massive
wingspan and the face of a primate.
While it’s unlikely such an organism ever
existed, the concept of a giant bat monster
isn’t too hard to reimagine as something
more biologically plausible.
The team envisions the Ahool as an unknown
bat-lineage even larger than the fox-faced
megabats.
A burly predator, the Ahool is able to walk
bipedally on the ground — bringing prey
to the forest floor after tackling them in
the air.
An aggressive carnivore, this creature possesses
a short snout that vaguely resembles the face
of a monkey.
All in all, it’s an astute reimagining of
a rather unlikely lifeform...
According to folklore, hidden in the misty
moors of Scotland lurks a spectral horse.
‘Kelpie’ is an old Scottish name for an
equine monster said to dwell within deep lakes,
hoping to drag unsuspecting travelers to a
watery grave.
Since horses aren’t amphibious, the Kelpie
is a challenging creature to reimagine as
a plausible lifeform.
But there are several hoofed mammal species,
like wildebeest or water buffalo, that do
routinely wallow in rivers and lakes.
More surprisingly, there are even some species
of chevrotain — bizarre animals also known
as ‘mouse-deer’ — that are known to
walk underwater along the bottom of pools.
So, the team imagines the Kelpie as giant
relatives of the chevrotain that possess thick
manes and cloven hooves that make them look
superficially horse-like from a distance.
Reimagining Kelpies as semi-aquatic chevrotains
could also explain their occasional carnivorous
behavior from the legends, as chevrotains
are omnivores.
The team imagines the Kelpie possess fang-like
teeth to drag prey into the water — which
would, on occasion, includes humans.
In the Likouala River region of the Congo
basin, a reptile-like creature with plates
on its back supposedly lurks in the swamp.
Upon hearing of this creature’s description,
some outsiders interpreted the beast — called
the Mbielu-Mbielu-Mbielu — as some kind
of aquatic stegosaur that had miraculously
survived the KT extinction event.
While this would be cool, it’s… quite
the leap to make, and even for their speculative
reimagining, the team found the stegosaur
explanation to be too far-fetched.
Darren Naish: “If you’re going to take
seriously that this is a real animal, then
stegosaur is way down the list of things you
could classify as probable.
And so, for Cryptozoologicon we thought, wait
a minute, there’s this group of relatively
large tropical African fish that have some
amphibious capability, and have dorsal finlets
forming, like, a single line along the top
of the body; they’re called the bichirs.
So, let’s have some fun with this.
What about the idea that Mbielu-Mbielu-Mbielu
is a gigantic, amphibious, unusual bichir.”
The team imagines that this speculative lifeform
uses its massive spines to send signals to
other members of its kind, and can clamber
onto land using its muscular front flippers.
It’s still a pretty extreme concept for
an animal — but less so than an asteroid-proof
aquatic stegosaurus.
Wherever a dark street winds through the countryside
in the United States, the Goatman is supposedly
on the prowl.
As the jokey nature of the name might suggest,
the Goatman is for the most part not taken
seriously, and is just meant to be a fun yet
spooky urban legend.
Exactly what the Goatman is and what it looks
like varies between stories, and is generally
just meant to be a vaguely-humanoid creature
that prowls around in the dark.
But playing the speculative game once more,
the team redesigns the Goatman as a large,
human-sized, North American monkey, uniquely
adapted for rapid bipedal running.
They picture these creatures as highly elusive,
able to rapidly sprint away from danger — hence
the confusion over their appearance.
It would certainly be a shock to encounter
such creatures, especially since the team
imagines they’d be capable of ferocious
aggression when the need arises...
In the mountains of New Guinea, a report from
the 1930s describes a creature from another
age.
Stunt pilot and self-described adventurer
Charles Miller claims he witnessed a towering
beast with a long neck and tail emerge from
the forest, which he believed to be a lost
Mesozoic dinosaur.
While the concept of dinosaurs surviving in
a lost valley somewhere was a bit of a cultural
phenomenon at the time, the report wasn’t
believed, and years later Miller all but admitted
he made the encounter up.
If Miller’s monster was a real lifeform,
the Cryptozoologicon team imagines that like
Mbielu-Mbielu-Mbielu it wouldn’t be a lost
dinosaur, but rather a dinosaur-like offshoot
of a modern genus.
Taking inspiration from the Galapagos tortoise,
they picture the creature to be a turtle offshoot
that evolved into a giraffe-like herbivore
in an isolated island environment.
While not quite a dinosaur, a giant, super-necked
tortoise would be a sight to behold…
Arguably one of the most fascinating episodes
in cryptozoological history comes from the
Colombian-Venezuelan border in 1929.
Here, Swiss geologist François De Loys took
a creepy photo of a deceased primate he claimed
was an undiscovered species.
The infamous photo was treated with immediate
skepticism, and has been largely proven to
be a white-faced spider monkey, that De Loys
propped up to make it appear larger than it
actually was.
But what if the De Loys Ape had been a real
animal?
The team envisions a primate that split off
from spider monkeys during the Pleistocene,
becoming large, bipedal ground-dwellers.
In our timeline, this lineage includes some
of the most intelligent and adaptable primates,
so it follows that the larger De Loys Ape
would be particularly smart, perhaps routinely
using tools and seeming almost human-like
when foraging and using weapons…
One of my absolute favorite aquatic cryptids
supposedly dwells in the waters of the north
Atlantic — the ‘long-necked seal.’
Most reports come from the 18th century, and
describe seal-like creatures with peculiar,
elongated necks.
The scarce sightings of this creature seem
to come from individuals who were unfamiliar
with the appearance of sea lions.
The team envisions long-necked seals as a
genus of pinnipeds that fill a unique ecological
niche.
Instead of pursuing fish in the open water,
these creatures munch on slow moving sea cucumbers
and starfish on the abyssal plain.
Their nostrils have evolved into protruding
breathing snorkels — meaning that unlike
common seals, long necked seals never have
to come ashore…
Off the coast of Alaska, another aquatic cryptid
comes in the form of the Tizheruk.
A sleek aquatic monster, it’s possible this
creature comes from real sightings of leopard
seals — although some legends describe it
as having horns.
Faced with such a strange mixture of features,
the team has come up with an ingenious speculative
solution.
They imagine the Tizheruk to be extraordinarily
large pinnipeds — perhaps related to their
version of long-necked seals.
They envision this creature would eat small
marine mammals, and even the occasional human
swimmer.
Instead of horns, this Tizheruk possesses
two soft, retractable structures on the top
of its head, which they inflate when displaying
to potential mates or rivals.
It’s an unusual feature, but when one is
trying to imagine a plausible version of a
seal with horns, one has to get creative...
And to conclude our experiment, one of the
most bizarre cryptids ever conceived comes
from the western United States in the form
of the Hoop Snake.
This creature comes from tall tales in the
1700s, which describe a snake that can travel
rapidly by grabbing its tail in its mouth
to form a hoop and roll like a living wheel.
Allegedly, Hoop Snakes would race across the
countryside in pursuit of prey.
As you can imagine, this sort of snake is
quite the challenge to redesign as a more
realistic creature — but not entirely impossible.
Unlikely as it might sound, Golden Wheel Spiders
do curl themselves into a ball and roll down
sand dunes to escape predators.
They don't form hoops like the eponymous snake
- but they at least show that there is a precedent
for turning yourself into a round thing and
rolling away at high speeds.
So, the team envisions a Hoop Snake that has
evolved in much the same way.
The imagined creature’s musculature is specialized
around supporting a wheel-shape, and its sturdy
bones are able to endure the bumps of the
road.
Furthermore, the interior of its mouth is
heavily keratinized and perfectly shaped to
latch on to its tail, with a thick keratinous
flap sealing the tail in place.
The western United States would certainly
be more perilous if deadly snakes could roll
around at high speeds, but I still find myself
wishing I lived in a world with Hoop Snakes...
But according to Darren Naish himself, just
because a creature likely doesn’t exist,
it doesn’t mean it can’t tell us something
about ourselves and our cultures.
Darren Naish: “I think Cryptozoology has
an enormous potential to teach us about how
we behave.
People have these particular kinds of creatures
as sort of fixtures of the imagination.
You go to a big, deep, cold lake, you look
in the water, there’s automatically the
idea — even if you see absolutely nothing
— there’s the idea that there could be
some giant scary and predatory monster in
the lake.
That’s a fixture of culture.
Our species as a whole, we often seem to have
the same kinds of creatures.
For me, Cryptozoology is culture — is firmly
embedded within cultures, whether those creatures
exist or not.”
A tremendous thank you to Darren Naish for
speaking to me about Cryptozoology.
Once again, you can purchase Cryptozoologicon
to see more reimagined cryptids and follow
and support the creators using the links in
the description below.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.